[Gelächter]
leute es wird wieder zeit spaß zu haben
neben ihr hüpft beck geisteskranke
störte abgeben ziel gesehen heute ist es
wieder zeit für eine nicht lachen
stellend die unsympathisch die koalition
hat sich sehr gut gefallen deswegen
machen sie heute weiter mit einer
installation aus dem netz zu biografien
die kommentare so sebastian du hast das
prinzip nicht ganz verstanden
zwei dinge dazu erstmal gleich viel
öfter als max mir sowas ist aber so in
mir drin ich muss einfach da lachen und
wie schneide ich natürlich auch im
schnitt mehr die stellen wo ihr lachen
wenn ich da sitze von video anschauen
ich lache ist ja auch langweilig also
wenn ich heute nicht lachen challenge
wieder komplett durchlaufen
wisst ihr wie diverse objektive ergänzen
diesen modus von dem für diesen modus
handle
doch solche sinnlosen hat wird starten
die brocken sind wir ganz kurz
was wir den menschen vor ort so was
passieren ganz kurze umfrage heute was
geht den menschen vor dass man einfach
so einen kranken pin schieb ich habe
auch mal der ausraster aber hat bin ich
jemals so extrem aus was auch mit der
stelle wurde ruhig um gesprungen bin ja
selbst auf den tisch gehauen habe das
kann's noch mal alles klar
[Musik]
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
weißt du was sein nein nicht nein
meist werden solche nein dinger montana
black also ok also das wird sich aber
wie er das vorbereitet wurde so ganz
unten raus gezogen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
tim gabe dieses letzte stück scheiße und
dann gibt es noch diesen text wie zwei
leben denken könnte so lautete wer zum
teufel nach dem 10
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wieder gewinnt wie unterschiedlich der
in jedem video auswählen minder von
festwirt jungen gemacht
ich bin mal zu 30 kilo weniger ist
natürlich zusammen stellt was den
zeitpunkt aber ich hab's wieder sich
auch verändert so optisch kann nicht
lossagen kennst du einen youtuber in
deutschland besuch solche anfälle hat
also nicht solche phase und es mir
möglich widget anfälle könnt ihr euch
eine solche anfälle ganz verboten
[Musik]
was war das wieder für eine feste alter
junge mann zwar dass gerade für eine
fresse hallo ich habe eine cola mal
getroffen
hier auch mal ein video von mir da zu
sehen da muss ich sagen relativ normaler
menschen dem moment crackers sorgen also
damals gewesen das sie damals mehr
ausgelastet ist hätte man nicht umhin
gehabt dass die personen die man gesehen
hat
[Musik]
diese frau wird
[Applaus]
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
wir sind am anfang bei uns dass gerade
eine familienfeier wäre es gut
weggesteckt
oben ist alles voll mit verwandten so 20
30 leute wir unseren kader gestrichenen
stellen vorher oben fragte jemand jowi
verdienst du eigentlich so hinkriegt
ich möchte von allen guten geistern
verlassen
heute bewegen ungefähr eine halbe stunde
lang weiter videos geschaut und es kann
nicht lustig ist mit dieses erste video
war witzig danach war einfach nicht so
witzig deswegen will ich sein magst du
gehst mir dein handy korrekt eindruck
von der strecke dann über leute haben
hier drin was das geht kollegin abdecken
hier habe ich euch hier verlinkt diesmal
eine co moderatorin von ella auf dem was
das geht kanal und die versuchte online
liebe zu finden kann was da abgeht aber
z